and so you do the work once to create
the book that book impacts thousands
tens of thousands maybe even millions of
people
right and so i think it's you know
social especially there's a huge
difference if i'm creating content on
social
that disappears from the news feed and
the longevity of that content is not
very good
i'm running on a hamster wheel of
content creation at least youtube
content
similar to a book it has longevity right
you create the content once and then
that thing
it continues to rank it continues to
bring in traffic
what if there was a way to dramatically
increase the money that you're making
from
youtube and your online business a way
to strengthen your personal brand and
position yourself as the go-to
authority in your topic and in your
industry
and what if there was a way to slingshot
ahead of the competition and build a
powerful
legacy through meaningful content that
outlives you well there is a way
and it's through writing a book and hear
me out i know we're content creators and
we're video creators and we're online
entrepreneurs
but writing a book is one of the most
powerful things you could ever do
to achieve all of the benefits i just
mentioned
and more and in this episode of the
podcast
you're going to be learning from
chandler bolt the
founder of self-publishing school and
he's going to be talking about
why and how writing a book can be the
best
decision you ever make to grow your
youtube channel your influence your
business and your
income we're going to be covering why
you should
self-publish a book the opportunities of
traditional publishing and
self-publishing who should self-publish
a book and
the best ways to monetize your
book so if you're actually ready to bolt
on additional income streams to your
youtube channel and accelerate your
authority
faster than ever before then buckle your
seat belt and get ready for this episode
of the think marketing podcast
[Music]
today we have chandler bolt on the
broadcast podcast he's the ceo of
self-publishing school
and he's the author of six best-selling
books
including his most recent book titled
published
he's a tedx speaker he hosts a couple
incredible podcasts
and his passion is to help people
write books so that they can grow their
income their
impact and grow their business and so
chandler thanks so much for coming on
the podcast today how's it going
i'm great great to be here thanks for
having me sean for sure and i want to
kick it off
if people are just meeting you what is
your story
related to how writing a book
transformed your life
yeah so i'm i'm a c-level english
student
and a college dropout with adhd
so kind of one of the last people you'd
ever think uh to
to write and publish a book but i went
from this guy who hated writing
and hated reading you know i was in all
ap classes except for english
because if you're in ap english you have
to write more papers you need to read
more books and i don't like doing that
and so i went from that to now books
have changed my life
when i dropped out of school i kept
learning as if i was in school i just
translated that to books
and i started writing books and so i
read 50 something books a year and
i've written six books and um that's the
impetus of
of how i created self-publishing school
and then kind of a little bit of a more
personal story
i had a i had a friend that passed away
when i was
about 21 years old and right in front of
me it was kind of a tragic accident
and um you know
right after he passed away i found out
that he had actually attended one of my
random
webinars and written a draft of a book
and
we were able to publish that after he
passed away and so that was a big part
for me where i was thinking about
pivoting into something else and then i
kind of took inventory of my life and
said hold up
this is one of the only things i'm doing
in my life that's actually having a
meaningful
impact on the world and making the world
a better place and
so that really kick-started me to double
down on self-publishing school and
uh i feel like it is now i'm living for
two and
you know i've got this bracelet that
says make him proud on one side
wwe kd what would kendall do on the
other side and so i feel like i'm living
for two and a big part of that is
is through the work that we're doing
with self-publishing school and helping
change more lives through books
bro that is a super powerful story and
it does make me think i'm a father now
got a six month old and you do start
thinking about
what you're leaving behind and you know
god forbid
tragedies like that happen but i think
as maybe fathers or business
leaders or or pastors or mentors or just
somebody that just has a message and
wants to help somebody
some somebody with something practical
by actually galvanizing and organizing
and putting
your content in a book it can outlive
you and really build a legacy
um that's super deep well well let's
break it down
why self-publish a book because there's
so many different reasons
so many people that listen to this are
youtube content creators
and kind of social media influencers and
they might here's the objection
dude like i am i'm publishing ig tvs i'm
publishing youtube videos
does anybody read books anymore what
good would it be for me to write a book
what would you say that
so i think there's why write and publish
in general and then there's
self-publishing versus traditional
publishing and so
i think probably the first question is
why even do it to begin with which is i
think is really the question that you
asked
and i believe it's it's one of if not
the most powerful way
to ways to grow your impact to grow your
income and to grow your business if you
have one
and so i mean it's follow your playbook
right sean this is what we talked
about when you came on the
self-publishing school podcast is
you know the ways that you embed youtube
secrets is like youtube seekers will be
the sponsor of one of your videos or
will be the call to action so
you're ascending a relationship in a low
ticket way so especially for folks who
are
uh you know creating content youtube
things like that
podcast whatever it's it's a it's a way
to ascend the relationship so i've gone
from a few
a a free viewer uh to a paid
purchaser of your book and so it's it's
a small piece of monetization
but then i'm deepening the relationship
significantly right then we're spending
hours together
and then if i have other products i can
ascend into those as well
if that's what you choose to do but from
as a business owner i look at
you know as a human i look at my books
as part of my legacy like you said it's
it's
the the thing that you know long after
i'm off this earth it'll still be here
you know maybe it'll just be at a
goodwill but it'll still be here right
it's part of my legacy
and then as a business owner i look at
it as a vehicle to generate more leads
sales and referrals for my business
so my most recent book published
generates
gosh i don't even know a few hundred
thousand dollars at least every single
year
um people buy the book or they'll get a
copy for free or
you know whether i'm speaking at events
or free plus shipping funnel or whatever
they read the book and then they say man
this is really helpful
i would love to work with
self-publishing school on this right so
you're
i call it a silent salesman you send the
book out in the world
and it brings back lead sales and
referrals for your business that's so
powerful you know i've also learned
that um which really is i think what
leads to the kind of those leads and
those sales
is is the authority like even still
books are still respected
and so by being able to say you're an
author and truly being one
um that's so helpful i think it's also
how it will help you personally level up
by going through the process of writing
youtube secrets i kind of
could scatter shot my advice before that
yeah and then after
it was much more organized i know
michael stelzner in the past
when talking about speakers at social
media marketing world he said one of the
kind of prerequisites
was he wanted people to be published
authors because all that meant to them
or self-published authors it just meant
if they had a book that they had
actually
organized their thoughts they had gone
through the heavy lifting of trimming
the fluff
putting it all together and so i believe
it sharpens you
as an educator it sharpens your
proprietary process it sharpens your
ideas it sharpens it forces you to
sharpen anything
so it would like a ripple effect through
all of my content
and i mentioned authority but i think
it's also positioning
even up until this point a couple other
people since then my friend daryl bryan
they've they put out some pretty good
books
but youtube secrets was like the first
one in our industry besides
a lot of really poorly written
30 page ebooks so all of a sudden
benji and i who co-authored the book had
like this this piece of positioning
in a digital social media space that
allowed us to just be at a whole nother
caliber
of authority and so there's been so many
benefits
yeah well and you know it's to speak to
those two things
the root word of authority is author
right you can't spell authority without
never heard that before and also
it's exactly what you said it forces you
to crystallize your thoughts and it's
intimidating this is why
a lot of people don't want to do it or
they feel uncomfortable doing it is
because
as you're writing it and i'm sure you
felt this it's
you're saying i'm crystallizing my
thoughts into the written word
and that means i have to figure out
what's my stance on this
but in doing so now you can speak
knowledgeably you can
break apart the book uh into into
you know those are individual talks so
those are individual videos and i think
you know if you're a content creator
already chances are you've already
created
at least a raw framework for your your
book right so you can
you can video record your way to your
book um
ministers or or pastors you can preach
your way like
your your sermon series is a book right
uh and
or or one of them is at least and so you
can break that out and you can still
cater to the medium that you do best
um but while also crystallizing your
ideas and what ultimately becomes a book
that's an encouragement the point you
mentioned there is you know
think marketing podcast listeners you're
hearing this
and you've already put out 100 video
ideas or 10 or 50
you've already published you know videos
or blog posts or podcast episodes
those are like chapters potentially or
those are potential chapters
and by putting your content out public
actually you've posted 50
youtube videos 10 did really well that
are that's like people saying those
should be the 10 chapters and the other
ones weren't as strong
and so there's so many powerful things
in there well i want to talk about
even who you think should publish a book
and some of the best ways to monetize
but before we get there
you you mentioned the kind of two
questions the difference between
traditional publishing and
self-publishing
someone's listening to this and they
want to write a book and they're
unfamiliar they're like i don't know
which path i wanted could i even get
traditionally published
should i go even pursue that route or
even if i could
should i still pursue self-publishing
what's kind of the difference break that
down
yeah so there's there's three or four
main differences it starts with
distribution
so it used to be that the only way to
sell books uh was to get your book in
the bookstores
right and to get into bookstores you had
to have a publishing deal to get a
publishing deal you had to have an agent
so you start way back here and you know
three years later you've got a book
that's out in the world well now
over 70 of all books sold are sold on
amazon
right and so and you don't need a
publisher to publish a book on amazon so
distribution has kind of fell by the
wayside as a as a major sticking point
and now it's really there's three main
differences there's the royalty rates
there's the time that it takes and then
there's the cost to publish
and so for royalty rates you're looking
at if you're traditionally publishing
eight to twelve percent so we're talking
a dollar maybe two
per book if you're self-published on the
other hand it's anywhere from you know
20
to 70 on the digital kindle version um
that's a big difference maybe that's
five to eight dollars a book depending
on pricing and stuff like that
and so that's the royalty rate
difference pretty big difference time it
takes
if you're traditionally publishing
minimum of two years
uh and then there's kind of uh and you
know if you're self-publishing
you know maybe it'll take you a year
maybe it'll take you a decade
depending on how disciplined you are we
i think the stats about
uh 60 or 70 of our students write and
publish
in less than a year so saving a bunch of
time in that process
and then there's the cost so obviously
if you're going traditional publishing
you know they're going to cover the cost
of publishing for you
then there's kind of this middle ground
which is hybrid publishing some people
call it vanity publishing
and this is where you pay someone most
often to publish your book
it might be five ten fifteen thirty
thousand dollars
and you're paying and sometimes you also
they also take a royalty cut kind of
depends
and then they're self-publishing
obviously which that means you're gonna
have to pay the cost yourself
and so big three costs sorry this long
answer
uh the big three costs are uh cover
design editing formatting those are kind
of your your main three costs
can cost anywhere from a few hundred
bucks to a few thousand bucks or
maybe more if you really don't know what
you're doing um or if you just want
like like spending money um then you can
spend more than that
but that's kind of the ballpark and but
the long and short of it is for 99.9
of authors uh it makes more sense to
self-publish
now disclaimer like i run
self-publishing school and i own
self-publishing.com
so obviously i'm biased but i really
think the only time it makes sense
to traditionally publish is if you're a
big name
with a big audience and you can get a
big advance
that's the only time so if you're you
know tony robbins
uh sean cannell uh uh oprah and you can
get a big advance
then awesome maybe that makes sense
maybe it still makes sense not to but
that's in my opinion the only time
uh it makes sense to do that it's kind
of like if you've ever heard the saying
it's like
banks only lend money to people who
don't need it uh
publishers only give publishing deals to
people who don't need it and who can
sell the books without them so
how about ownership because i mean one
of the other reasons why i love
self-publishing school
or i love self-publishing school as well
but self-publishing
is you got the rights to your book uh
and like i know that's maybe if you
traditionally publish like they kind of
own rights and maybe yeah solution for a
certain number of years or you might
even have to buy it back or it's not
released
often in perpetuity and and depending on
how well you negotiate the contract
um they'll own the content in perpetuity
at least in book form
now sometimes you can also this is a a
small tip if you're going the
traditional publishing route negotiate
out there's a few things you should
negotiate you should negotiate out your
audiobook rights
that's really important because now um
that's a
separate income stream for you and a lot
of publishers don't think about that
uh there's two there's you can negotiate
out foreign rights
you can also negotiate your author the
price of
how many author copies they send you and
the price that you can purchase author
copies at
which if you want to sell books
elsewhere um
or or buy books or you know use them as
part of speaking events or whatever you
definitely want to negotiate that and
then there's a bunch of other stuff
um but yeah typically to answer your
original question the publisher owns
uh the the rights to the book in
perpetuity
yeah so from my point of view and
pre-youtube secrets which is
self-published we thought a ton about
this and already had influence that we
could have pursued the other route
um and by the way if you want to learn
more about this chandler and i um
have a training that we're doing
together it's live or if uh you want to
catch the replay depending on when
you're listening to this podcast
at startyourbook.live if you really want
to go deeper and how you can get your
book written in just 90 days
from literally blank page to getting it
live on
amazon and uh if you're thinking about
writing a book
you know on the idea of self-publishing
to me the huge thing was kind of that
rights thing because i also thought
man if i could get some practice get a
book or two under my belt even if i had
more celebrity later
those other books would have lift and i
would have the as opposed to the reverse
being that like oh shoot what if it
blows up what if it goes really big
because you could always inject new life
into it like almost like i could go
self-publish first maybe traditional
published later
and i could activate my back catalog
with a greater level of profitability as
opposed to getting
you know one or two or s or have the
right to even sell it later and now i'm
worth more
it's sort of like that idea it's kind of
like the record industry where all of a
sudden you blow up and now like you're
in a bad contract
yes oh 100 and a lot of people will do
that some people don't right like
a lot of people they'll self-publish the
book and they'll sell so well that they
get it
it'll get picked up by a traditional
publisher and they'll get a better deal
which is amazing uh and and that works
really well for them but then
even and some people choose not to like
i just did a
a webinar earlier today with how i'll
ride he sold like 2.5
million copies or something of his
self-published book the miracle morning
and publishers are just throwing money
at him trying to buy the rights to that
book and he's like
no show me the math okay now i'm going
to make way more money
i'm self-publishing a book or keeping
this book self-published
he parlayed that into his book the
miracle equation
and got a good deal for that and so
that's traditionally published and then
kind of
so that you get a big advance and he did
well with that and then you still have
the cash cow of your first book
and then also um you know even something
as simple as
one of the one a really effective thing
that helps sell more books is running uh
amazon ads
i always say that you know google is a
search engine of browsers amazon is the
search
engine of buyers everyone's focused on
seo on the google side of things
but amazon people are there for one
reason and one reason only that's to buy
stuff with their credit card on file
so i would rather rank i mean i'd like
to rank on both obviously we're actively
working towards that we do rank on both
but i would rather rank on amazon
because there's lower competition
and if i want to run ads i can't do that
if i have
like all my friends that are
traditionally published i'm like hey
go through and set up your amazon it's
like i can't
the publisher owns that and i'm offering
to pay them money and they won't even
set up amazon ads right so even just
small
simple things like that where you have
the control of your book you can market
it the way you want
you can get like i give away the audio
book for free that means
tons of leads so i'm getting paid to get
leads instead of paying for leads
like all those little things like that
you
in a lot of cases you just can't do if
you're traditionally published
that's super powerful and yeah we are in
constant positive roi
running ads on youtube secrets ebook
which also means we're meeting new
people which kind of gets us set teed up
for
best ways to monetize your book what it
can lead to um but just really quick
so who should self-publish a book so i
just think
in our community uh nicole kid's
occupational therapist hundred thousand
youtube subscribers oh my gosh
i mean like right like she could write
like for new moms
like a motherhood a motherhood uh
fly ride he does custom led lighting
he's also kind of into building
businesses and he's now scaling
an influencer he's on clubhouse a lot
he's scaling um
he's doing a lot of kind of social media
stuff so that could be interesting
because maybe i don't know if you'd buy
a book about custom led lights
but he's now built 10 different income
streams
around what was a traditional uh
business
ben from keto camp he's got his book
coming out of course ketosis and
you know that's a big one so i just
think about you know again i think that
youtube content creators
might have not thought about doing this
but i think it's one of the smartest
it's not necessarily that's where you
come in it's not easy it's really easy
to get off the rails
it's really easy to heather's actually
working on uh
her book right now and it's had her in
tears
because it's emotional like it's a you
know yes it's it's the kind of thing
it's free therapy no doubt about it
if you're writing about a personal topic
it's free therapy like you're gonna have
to work through some stuff
yeah and so uh but but who should
self-publish a book
i mean you've helped so many people what
are some of the stories that are just
remarkable about some books that have
gotten off the ground that have helped
people scale
whatever they're doing in marketing or
social or some other weird kind of
business
i'd say you know there's there's kind of
two camps there's the legacy camp and
then there's the business camp
um some people are saying hey i just
want to do this and if no one but my
kids and my grandkids read this
i'm good and then other people say hey i
want to very strategically
use this book um to grow uh grow a
business and
so we've got so many examples on both
sides of that spectrum one of my
favorites
uh is we had someone joined
self-publishing school years ago
to write a book about physical therapy
and back pain
really awesome doing an amazing thing
he's a physical therapist
but then his daughter saw it and said
hey dad that's really cool i want to
write a book
and he said all right well why don't you
write you know 500 words and come back
to me
and thinking like okay i'm going to
brush her off and
this she's just saying this she's not
going to actually do it and then she
comes back like a couple hours later and
she's got
words written and so then they worked
kind of ev
every saturday at panera bread for weeks
and then she published a book
it made three or four thousand dollars
in the first few months she donated a
bunch of money to autism awareness
like now she's been on all these local
tv shows
she's she's doing speaking gigs she made
like 1200 bucks or something from her
first speaking gig
like eight years old and now it's just
like i think about her life trajectory
as a young woman and just the confidence
like the opportunity she has a
monthly allowance which is really just
her book royalty money that shows up
every month right like
just life trajectory totally changed and
that's one of my favorite stories and so
a good example for the parents as well
of like hey
if you decide to do this your kids are
watching and
they're paying attention and when you go
after your goals they see that and they
might want to do it too
i love that and i i mean i was kind of
taught in this
even coming up chalene johnson who i
know you know and have done stuff with
uh it helps you as a speaker you know
like
if you have even you may be more in
demand as a speaker because like oh
you're a published author plus it could
be the thing that happens from on stage
my friend rory vaden was on the podcast
books have been a huge
you know thing for him obviously so many
different people whether you're s
sp you've talked about the business camp
man if you've got a proprietary process
if you
are a coach a consultant and it also can
help you
carve out a whole new side of of
business and i think one of the big
things that's interesting is
i think sometimes we we just have this
myth of
well i create all this content on social
media i've reached the maximum market
you know of course i want to grow on
google or social more
like does anybody even read books it's
like are you kidding it's a whole nother
actual
side and then like audiobooks a whole
nother conversation
like some of the gen z people from our
team they're literally like i don't read
books
but i listen audiobooks all the time
like i'm i'm just addicted to autumn
so once you've actually written the book
now you're gonna get it in audio form
and that's a whole nother arm like
what's the opportunity there and that
kind of ties more into this
this youtube thing because we're here on
a podcast it's also a video podcast
yes but the audio is the person people
are watching on their phone listening on
their phone they're listening to itunes
to move over to audible or whatever
and and start consuming that audio while
they're driving while they're
on you know doing chores while you're on
a walk
it scales like our friend pat flynn says
it scales intimacy
because yeah someone watched you've seen
audience retention on a youtube video
it's two minutes
four minutes even of a 25 minute video
someone commits to you in an audiobook
now they've spent even if they don't
finish it
an hour with you two hours with you
three hours of view you read it yourself
they're hearing your voice
they're learning more about you and
there's such another level of depth
which speaks to that a thousand true
fans it speaks to that like
deeper than just vanity surface level
social media
media metrics but really going deeper
what are some of the things that people
do with audio books with you guys
yeah so i i think you spoke to a really
crucial distinction sean
which is i i i call this concept
leveraged impact
so it's doing work once and so you do
the work once to create the book
and then that that that book impacts
thousands tens of thousands maybe even
millions of people
right and so i think it's you know
social especially there's a huge
difference if i'm creating content on
social
that disappears from the news feed and
the longevity of that content is not
very good
i'm running on a hamster wheel of
content creation this is what i love
about you what
you guys are teaching on youtube and why
you know i
i bought your course and sent my team
through it and we're creating youtube
content and all that because
at least youtube content similar to a
book it has longevity
right you create the content once and
then that thing it continues to rank it
continues to bring in traffic like
there's longevity so
leverage impact you're you're creating
it once and then yes then you add in the
audio book component
and if you have a podcast it's a
no-brainer because the people who listen
to your podcast
would buy your audiobook and so there's
an instant crossover
there's all kinds of minutiae things
that are kind of cool like
the audible bounty which is when people
go to try audible and you're the first
book that they download
whether you did that or just it just
happened audible pays you they're always
changing it but it's like 50 75 100
bucks
so i i have a few hundred bucks a month
that comes in just from audible bounties
right
and so that's another stream of income
and there's people
you know listening to the audiobook and
then and then it gets into the stuff
that i'm i'm sure we'll talk about more
in depth later but
where i look at it as a business owner
again is it leads
sales and referrals and so leads or
people that have heard of me because of
my book
right how many people wouldn't have
heard of clickfunnels if it wasn't for
russell brunson's books
right so new people in your ecosystem
then there's sales so getting a higher
percentage of people who heard about you
to do business with you
as kind of like a a transfer mechanism
so just like you do
use the book as part of your webinar use
the book as part of the sales process
and you're going to see a conversion
rate lift
on all those things and then lastly for
as a referral mechanism
so give two copies to every
customer right and say hey here's one
for you and here's one for a friend you
know that needs help with
xyz i do this all the time and i think
we've been in events together and
whenever i'm speaking i bring hundreds
of books and give them all away
because then it's like there's just an
army of people and
everyone around the conference is like
wait what hold up what's that
and then some people don't even read the
books but they'll you know it's like if
i would have gave him a business card
they would have thrown it away
probably within 24 hours but now they're
holding that book they take it home they
don't throw it away it's in their home
it's in their office and every time they
see it
they think of me in self-publishing
school and then maybe they
they don't even want to publish a book
but someone comes by their house at
their office and says hey what's that
and they say oh you want it you can have
this copy right
and so you're you're turning customers
or prospects into
a referral engine as john janse would
call it
for your book and so that's how i look
at it kind of the three buckets as an
entrepreneur of how do i plug the book
into what i'm already doing to bring
back leads sales referrals
man super super powerful and if you're
like
fired up by everything that chandler's
saying and you want to learn more about
this
especially like what is the i mean we
haven't really got into how do you start
to self-publish your book how do you
start writing it
you might have a lot of mindsets of
self-doubt like oh do i have anything to
say
or i'm not a good writer um i wasn't
good in english like these things can
kind of hold us back and that's where
chandler's process can really help you
if you want to watch the free training
of course at the end of it you'll learn
more about all the ways that
self-publishing in school can help you
but the
free training alone is so valuable that
uh we're doing together it's that start
your book
and you can watch that free
webinar and that's uh what are they
going to learn on that training
yeah so um you'll learn three things so
you're going to learn
how to write your book in as little as a
weekend which i know probably sounds
crazy
but i'll teach you the three-step
process to either write your book or
speak your book if you choose to do it
that way kind of a choose your own
adventure
we'll go more in depth on
self-publishing versus traditional
publishing
and then we're going to talk about how
to use or how to launch your book
successfully so i've got something
really cool that i'll talk about on the
launch front
uh that'll help you get more reviews and
have a more successful launch
with your book so those are the core
things and practicing what i'm
what i'm preaching here uh when you
register for the training
if you show up live and stay to the end
you'll get a copy of my book
my book published so we'll send you a
digital copy of the book
uh when you register is it start at
startyourbook.live
yeah yeah so definitely check out that
training as we land the plane i do want
to just kind of rapid fire on some ways
to monetize i mean if people already go
if i get the leads i can monetize
maybe you could share some stories and
again i want people to hear
this is coming out of my own experience
i wanted to have chandler on because i
believe so much in the power of a book
there's a level of of just pride
accomplishment
um you know confidence
that is intangible and you don't know
until you're on the other side of that
book
yeah just the blood sweat and tears that
goes into it and from
you know following a proven process i
definitely say don't go it alone because
it's super scary and i think most people
they start but they never actually get
their book public i love your results of
of your students but we've seen physical
books
have made sales ebooks we actually are
now
in digital international sales from
ebooks but we've also had foreign rights
and because we self-published we i think
you know it's we feel blessed i think it
was korean chinese
russian we just got that cover and
vietnamese
so far i'm not sure why not spanish i'm
like come on man i mean spanish big
market but uh just people that are
interested in youtube secrets
so a lot of different things can happen
the audiobook the royalties um
what's like a you know a story or an
example of just somebody who they wrote
their book and man it led to
monetization that they
kind of surprised them yeah i would say
there's there's one or two examples that
just jump to the top of my head first of
which i think will be super applicable
for your audience
um a guy named david mckay um so you you
know this sean my brother plays in the
grammy-nominated
rock and roll band called need to
breathe um they were playing at red
rocks one year
and i met this guy he was he was a
photographer and he was taking pictures
and uh and he he he followed up after
him was
gonna work with you guys and i think he
still has record
he wrote in public he he wrote and
published 89
sorry two books within 89 days of
starting work with us
crazy um but what that did is he emailed
me the other day said hey it's been one
year since i've been self-publishing
school
over ten thousand dollars in royalties
nice but more importantly
forty five thousand dollars in business
from his book so basically
he does photography tours where they
take people out in nature like
africa and like all this stuff uh and so
people read the book about how to do
photography
uh and then they see that he does tours
and then they book
photography tours with him in year one
um 45 000
worth of tours that he could track was
directly from the book
he says those those books bring in about
30 to 40 leads per week again
instead of paying for leads he's getting
paid to get leads
and then he just emailed me over
christmas i think it was and he was like
yeah another 20 something thousand
dollars worth of tours
like and this is another person that
that came from my books
and just a gift that keeps on giving and
then another another example
um this guy scott groves he had he had a
crazy amount of words like 500 000 words
or something
and it was like man i've been working on
this for four years
um i i need to pay you to actually get
it done
uh and uh he scrapped all of it
and wrote and published it in in i think
it was 90 days
and he's um he's a mortgage broker
uh and it was like within gosh four
months five months or something like
a few thousand dollars in royalties i
think is eight thousand dollars in
royalties
got a 59 000 a year pay bump at his job
hired a new employee that found it
because of his book and it was like
two deals that was worth like 60 000
in commissions or something like that
and and that was
i mean it crystallized it finished his
book i think he
like locked himself in a hotel room for
a weekend or something
got the book done um and then used it to
start growing his business
man i love hearing that too and when i
think mortgage broker and you know what
makes me think is it makes me think
personal branding it makes me think
real estate agent mortgage broker doula
you know fitness coach man yes if you
don't have a book
that's you're like you're just another
like everyone else
but you take him he writes the book now
all of a sudden you come in with another
it's forced you to level up yeah all
that in the person on the other side of
that interview or the job you're in gets
that promotion
but even in terms of attracting top
talent or building a team
now it's like oh because because again
you're you're you're published author
you you you've got that authority piece
or you don't know who's reading your
book
and they're getting to know you in that
intimate
way and you don't even know it yet and
then all of a sudden they're up to speed
or they're
you've articulated your mission your
mission your vision
your values in your book yeah and now
they want to be a part of what you're
doing
and so it could lead to partnerships
collaborations you have a stronger
personal brand
more revenue more leads your business is
growing the power of a book
chandler that's why i had to have you on
the podcast
because there's just so many benefits
it's not easy
it's a lot easier if they go through a
proven process and people actually
always you know there's two ways right
to uh to get wisdom
one way is the slowest way your own
mistakes and maybe never actually
figuring it out and
taking forever or the the the better way
is other people's mistakes like
somebody's already figured
out like don't go that way the time to
have the map
is before you enter the woods and so
that you can follow
a proven plan but nevertheless my hope
in everybody listening to this
is that you would seriously consider
whether today is the right time or
whether it's sometime later that you
would make it one of your ambitions and
your goals
to say man if i want to take my business
to the next level my personal brand
i want to stand out in the sea of
sameness of social media influencers
then i want to write a book if any if
only to also get that in that audiobook
format
because man we've generated like over 40
000
just on the audiobook side not from our
products and programs
literally just from audible bounties and
audible and we've done things at scale
but like you said
every single video on video influencers
pretty much is like
this video is brought to you by tube
secrets book
tube secrets audio dot com get the
number one best-selling youtube strategy
book for free
because if you don't have audio and it's
a 15-second ad spot
rinse and repeat and we've done it for a
couple years and people continue to grab
the audio book for free or they already
have an audible book account
so friends i hope you will
check it out or think about writing a
book and if you want some help
chandler's got you and you can
check out the training that we did
together at start your book dot live
chandler if people want to connect with
you
where are you at yeah um i'm pretty i'm
old school so i'm literally only on
social
or sorry only on facebook uh and then
we're uh you know
self-publishing school website or
selfpublishing.com
uh otherwise i'm on facebook i love it
well chandler thanks so much for coming
on the podcast appreciate you
and i look forward to seeing everybody
over on the training at
startyourbook.live
so i hope you got value out of that
conversation with chandler bolt but
there is still
so much to come on the podcast so stick
around and the first thing is
if you have been getting value out of
the think marketing podcast and you
haven't left
a review it would mean the world to me
and the team
if you would just drop a review on apple
podcasts in fact
you can go to thinkmarketingshow.com and
we're actually doing a giveaway
of an all access pass to our conference
grow with video live
and all you got to do is it breaks down
all the steps you can leave a review you
like text us a picture of the review
and then you're entered to win a free
virtual pass
to the number one youtube marketing
conference for
entrepreneurs and smart business owners
grow with video live and so check all
that out thinkmarketingshow.com and
if you watch or listen to the think
marketing podcast on youtube of course
smash the like button and leave a
comment
i would love to know your biggest
takeaway from today's
episode now maybe chandler really got
you fired up about
writing a book and i want to encourage
you don't miss
the training we are doing together at
start your book dot
live if you want to be a part of a free
workshop
on how to go from blank page to
published
author in 90 days the busy person's
guide to getting it done in just 30
minutes a day
then you're gonna love that training
you're gonna learn the three-step system
that chandler uses to write publish
and launch listen a best-selling book
in as little as 90 days and then also
how to use your book to leave a legacy
you're going to find your book idea in
under an hour
you're gonna find how he wrote his first
book over 200 pages in just one week
how to leverage your book to grow your
authority income in business
how he made four thousand dollars a
month in book royalties and with his
first book he used it to grow a seven
figure company in just two years
a lot of stuff covered on the training
if you want to be a part of it
i'm going to be there with chandler i
hope you're there
start your book.live to register now of
course we always want to be transparent
with you at the fake marketing podcast
at the end of the training chandler's
going to let you know that
if you want to work with him and he
helps you through self-publishing school
writes your book
you know you have some kind of a special
offer but either way whether you want to
go it alone
and learn the information and then you
know
sit down at microsoft word and figure it
out and type your book out and use the
tips
don't miss the training and whether
you're like you know what this seems
like it'll be an awesome thing for me
then don't miss the training and you can
see what the next steps are as well but
if you have
any interest at all and you see the
power
of publishing or self-publishing your
own book
and what that could do for you as an
authority
as a content creator as an entrepreneur
as a small business owner someone who
just wants to leave a legacy or a memoir
for your family
then don't miss the training again start
your book.live
and you can be there uh for the training
if you're watching this sometime in the
future i think the replay will be left
up
for at least a little while and so start
your book
dot live is the website it is time
this is what happens when heather is not
doing the intros and outros of the
podcast
you've got sean's sound effects
but it's time for the comment of the day
and the t5 guy says this
this podcast is legit i've been
following think media youtube channel
for about a year and i decided to jump
into the youtube game
i found this podcast and it is so rich
sean really gives great insight on
marketing growing your channel and
providing better content
my biggest takeaway in the end is that
sean stresses that
it's about being a better human being
start and end there and you will find
success
the t5 guy thank you so much for leaving
the comment and i hope you did it
at thethinkmarketingshow.com take a
screenshot of it you can still do it
and submit that so we get you entered to
win
a free virtual pass to growth video live
2021. of course we'll tell you more
about
growth video live in the future it's not
until the end of august and 2021
so there's definitely time but uh we
will be bringing you more information
from that
but in the meantime leave a review and
you will be entered to win
one of three i believe virtual passes
for that now i want you to get ready
because next week we're kind of doing
part two of this podcast but it's going
to be a little bit different
we're going to keep talking about books
and why
you may want to write a book but
specifically i am going to be sharing
the untold story of youtube secrets
now the book uh youtube secrets that i
co-wrote with my friend benji travis
i believe is at around 70 000
copies now sold between ebooks physical
books audiobooks downloaded
um and we've learned so many lessons we
did a lot of things right
because we got help you know that's why
you connect with people like chandler
you get
help so you can shorten your learning
curve and you can learn someone who's
gone the path before
we also made a lot of mistakes so i'm
going to be talking about the good the
bad and the
ugly of the youtube secrets journey and
i'm going to be talking about how to 10x
your brand and your business with
the book i'm going to be sharing all the
numbers the details the units sold
the things we learned the campaigns we
did and you'll see
why this is so powerful to do as a
content creator if you have a cooking
channel maybe it's a cookbook
definitely if you're heather taurus and
it's about homeschool it could be
something in education or homeschool
maybe it's personal development or
self-development if you're nicole
in the think media community it could be
around parent coaching how to raise
parents how to be a parent how to keep
your
sanity as as a mom it could be around
relationships money motivation
memoir fiction whatever
maybe not every youtube channel but a
majority of youtube channels maybe not
every business owner but pretty much
every business owner every entrepreneur
should really consider
how writing a book will burst boost your
personal brand
not only on the uh training with
chandler not only in this episode and
you learned a lot but i'm just excited
to kind of go deep and tell the story
of the lessons i learned next week so
stick around make sure you're subscribed
whether you consume the think marketing
podcast on youtube hit the subscribe
button
if you are on apple podcast make sure
you get subscribed or
any of the audio platforms because we
will be back
every single tuesday with a brand new
episode
to help you reach your goals with
youtube and building a
business around your youtube channel
with the think marketing podcast i
appreciate you
grateful for you it's time to take
action hashtag action takers
let's get to work and make our next best
video
post those videos punch fear in the face
punch perfectionism in the face
and just press record and we will talk
soon
[Music]
you